Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters. Welcome to another edition of Cutters Clinic Live.
Today we have a special guest who I met a few months ago when she interviewed me for a summit
and we really hit it off but I wanted to have her on our podcast. Dr. Jed practices in Ohio,
she's a doctor of osteocathy and she really practices functional medicine work and won't
look at her tell us about herself and we'll have a great conversation. Hi Dr. Jed.
Hi Dr. Cutters, thank you so much for having me today. Absolutely. So tell us about you,
how did you get into functional medicine, getting a degree in osteopathy, kind of standard,
teach you functional medicine stuff at osteopathic school these days, right?
Thank you. No, you know what they don't and kind of an interesting story. I was at Kent State for
undergrad and I was loving medicine. I knew I wanted to go into medical school and then I had this
gospel choir class and one of the ladies that sat next to me and sang beautiful soprano voice,
she was a DO and she was a family practice DO and she's like, why don't you come and shadow me
and that is how I first found out about MD versus DO, how they see the body more as a whole
and you get more of that osteopathic manipulation where you can help the body kind of go back
into homeostasis through using your hands and in manipulations of some sort similar to
to chiropractors what they use. So I fell in love with DO school. I only applied to DO school
and then I went through DO school, loved the OMT. I met a lot of like-minded people in there. There
was a massage therapist that was in the military, did a lot of massage work, taught me about trigger
points. There was a chiropractor from Canada and my med school class, so really cool things.
Then I chose emergency medicine. So it's kind of interesting because you don't use a lot of OMT
there, but I do. I still put it in there, but I chose emergency medicine. It was just a calling to
me. I won't go through residency. I'm out as a practicing physician, board certified emergency
medicine doctor and a more community hospital. And the patients I were seeing were just sick. They
were chronically ill and I remember this one patient. She was about late 20s, early 30s and she saw
me every week and you're not supposed to see your emergency medicine physician that much. So
when you were working at ER, what was she doing coming to the ER every week? Yeah, she would come
in that much and with chronic abdominal pain. And when you're in the ER, you can only offer so much.
So I had to have a sit down moment with her and I'm like, look, you're going to have radiation
poisoning from all these CT scans of your abdomen. And I'm like, this is more of a chronic thing going
on and I encouraged her to do a food journal. I spoke with her about exercising, basically just lifestyle
things. And you know, that was kind of the light bulb moment that in having my first son, I was like
conventional medicine doesn't work. There's this whole other world out there of things like chronic
disease, like Lyme, Epstein, Bar. You know, I started just being obsessed with learning things
outside the box. I shadowed someone that while he didn't do formal training and functional or
integrative medicine, he was practicing treating chronic Lyme patients. And I said to my husband,
I'm like, I have to go back and do an integrative medicine fellowship. And I'm like, it's two years,
I can do it while I'm raising kids and working in the ER. And he was supportive. And he said, yes,
I'm going to support you doing this. So shortly after that, I opened my own integrative medicine practice
while still working part time in the ER, I was, how many kids? I was three kids in at that time.
And I remember I was building up my integrative practice when I was pregnant with my three-year-old,
I was a couple years in, and then COVID hit. And that was crazy, too. So, you know, it just has been
this journey of being a conventional medicine doctor and still working in the ER during COVID, still working
in the ER. But knowing that I want to stop people from getting to that chronic disease, because most
of the patients I see in the emergency room are products of chronic illness. And, you know, let that
sink in, right? Because we think of the emergency room for things like car accidents or, you know,
finger lacerations or broken bones, but that's really not what we're seeing. We're seeing consequences
of chronic disease and illness, which is sad. Well, that's, that is a light bulb moment for me,
because if somebody said, what do you usually, what would you see in the emergency room? I think
somebody got caught with a chainsaw or something like that. So, that's kind of sad. Because really
standard emergency room doctors have no idea how to deal with that, and they really, it's
beyond their scope of practice in the emergency room to even be able to deal with that if they do.
So, that what do you see in your practice? Yeah, so one of my main things I love to treat
is thyroid patients, specifically Hashimoto's and autoimmune problems, because I was diagnosed with
Hashimoto's disease myself. And now I am in remission. I checked my antibodies already once in a
while every couple of years now, and it's still good. So, what had happened for me was when I was in
high school, it's actually a really interesting story. So, I was having some cycle problems,
like a regular cycle, kind of delayed. And my mom read an article in like one of those prevention
magazines that you should have your kid's thyroid check. So, she actually went out and asked for a
thyroid test from my doctor, because no one had offered it. And that led to them getting an ultrasound
of my thyroid. And I had this nodule. They'd played around with thyroid medications to like
shrink the nodules, never looking for a root cause. Why? No one checked my antibodies even. So,
fast forward from high school to medical school, I was feeling my, I was palpating my thyroid because
we were doing anatomy. And I was like, oh my goodness, that nodule is big. It has tripled in size.
So, that led to another ultrasound to them. Then the doctors made, you know,
we did the, the fine needle biopsy and they're like, we have to roll out cancer. So, I was in my first
year of medical school. We, you know, I had to go to surgery. It was after our final test. I remember
because I had to fast. And I'm like, I'll take my test and then I'll go to surgery. And they,
they put me under and they're like, if it's cancer, then obviously we have to take out the
thyroid and do radioactive iodine treatment. And if it's not, then, you know, praise the Lord,
right? And I woke up and they were like, good news. It's not cancer. And then the surgeon,
I remember this. He looks at me and he's like, it was just Hashimoto's thyroiditis. And I'm like,
well, I was just a first year of medical student. I'm like, what's that? He's like, oh, it's just
a disease. You don't do anything about it. Eventually, it will burn out your thyroid. And I'm like,
oh, okay, you know, I'm a medical student. I'm going to listen to the conventional medicine doctor.
And even under technology, you really offered me no other treatment for Hashimoto's. So, they actually
took out half of my thyroid and the ismith, which is what connects it because it looked damaged
and diseased from the Hashimoto's little, you know, I mean, I wish I could go back in time and say,
please just keep that because I can heal it myself, right? So then fast forward to when I was
getting into the conventional, out of the conventional model, into the integrative model, I actually,
I cut out gluten. I healed my gut health, which had so many problems. And I reversed my Hashimoto's.
And it's, and I feel better now than I did in my 20s, you know, because when you really have that
thyroid disease, it's, you don't, you don't feel good unless you're putting all the different
puzzle pieces together and really looking at the whole body. And that's gut health, adrenal health,
mitochondrial health. So hormone health, insulin glucose, you know, the things that you do, right?
Dr. Conner's like, it's, it's all, it all needs to be just running perfectly like a well oiled
machinery. So for me, doing what I do now is just almost redeeming. I wish that there was doctor
like me. And if there was, I'm sure my mom would have taken me to them, but even now there's just
a not enough integrative and functional care. And it really should be the standard of care when it
comes to most diseases at this point. Well, I hear this so often in the same, have the same
testimony is that you get into natural care because of your experience. And so many doctors have that
same, you know, testimony is how they got into care. Because honestly, who, why else would you want
to get into this, you know, especially in an era, I mean, now it's more accepted. But when I
graduated in the 80s, I mean, it was voodoo. And we got so ridiculed. And, you know, just, you know,
trying to make it was difficult you, you know, and there's a lot of negatives. So, but people
did it because of their experiences. And it is really, you know, natural care, functional medicine
care has grown because of that grassroots efforts of practitioners and the grassroots experiences of
their patients that are not demanding it. So it is a growing profession. I would agree that there's
not enough people out there that know enough about autoimmune disease like Hashimoto.
Then there should be because Hashimoto's is like exploding autoimmune diseases aren't
exploding after COVID. And nobody knows how to take care of these people are very few practitioners
do. What is what have you seen with post COVID doing to your practice? Well, yes. I mean, that
that is one thing. I was just reflecting on it because I watched a certain Joe Rogan interview
and I was in tears and I'm so glad that I have no regrets. And I'm sure you the same no regrets
that how I handled the whole pandemic as a physician. And I treated people that needed treated
because what I'm seeing post now is that those that were not treated appropriately and properly
when having COVID, you know, that spike protein is just doing major damage. And what is
underlying is coming out. So I have a patient that he, his was actually triggered by not by the
infection but by the actual vaccine that he had mold toxicity. And that that trigger that he got
that shot really just brought that mold like his, his immune system can crashing down after that.
So now we are, we are removing, we removed him from the environment from the mold. I put him on
Lodo's Naltrexone. Naltrexone, we did a little bit of Ivermectin. We used some peptides to
balance his immune system. And he went from not being able to work. He had to stop work and now he
is back on his boat. And he needs to get his strength back because he was in the hospital. He lost a
lot of muscle mass. So we're working on that. But lots of stories like that, you know, in fertility
issues problems with the cycle I'm seeing and explosion like you said of poshimoto's,
I actually just had a new patient that had hypochiridism for decades. And now is having poshimoto
antibody show up. So you know, and I tell them it's just whatever trigger it is whether it's mold or
lime or a virus, you know, Epstein bar used to be the most famous. And now it's probably going to be
COVID is the biggest autoimmune trigger coming up. So it's, it's all about controlling the inflammation,
rebuilding the gut health, which is therefore balancing the immune system. So it's it's scary.
What are you seeing? I just want to know in your clinic, is it exploding with cases that you're
dealing with for cancer post pandemic? Oh, absolutely. It's just literally exploded. And anybody that
has had the vaccine, it's, it's just made their problems worse. People or in complete revision,
all of a sudden their cancer just took off and exploded again. People that were not diagnosed
of cancer, now diagnosed of cancer. And like you said, even if a person didn't get vaccinated,
the exposure to the spike proteins from other people has caused ill effect. And we're seeing,
you know, autoimmune disease go through the roof. You know, to this, at this point, it's not,
I hope I don't get an autoimmune disease. And more, it's like a wonder which autoimmune disease I'm
going to get first, because you'll probably get many. So it's, we live in a crazy world. We used to
talk about mainly the toxins and the poisons from pesticides and things that know their man made
the poisons that were dealing with in the, in the, as the source of virus and things like that. So it is,
it, we really need a lot more practitioners out there to be able to help these people. Because
like you said, it used to be like an empty bar virus that would be a trigger. So for the listeners
to understand, you made mention of somebody with primary hypothyroidism and flipped out to
Hashimoto's, there's a difference like your, your baking reference to, there's a very big difference
between somebody with primary Hashimoto, primary hypothyroid. That is not an autoimmune disease. To
now having Hashimoto's or graves or, you know, some other autoimmune component, that's a big difference
in how you treat that. It's a big difference in that, what that's going to do to that person's lifestyle.
And, you know, both of us are big proponents of getting people tested for autoimmune diseases
because so many chronic disorders people can't figure it out, can't put their figure on it. But they've
never been tested for anybody. So you made mention of your life that you went to doctors and they never,
you thyroid issues that they'd ever tested. You've heard antibodies, TPO, or thyroid
immunity bodies. So that's just such a disservice. You see that, you see that today. I mean, that was
maybe years ago for you, but I just had somebody other day that thyroid issues and did they test
you for anybody's here. They sent me the blood test. No, they did TSH and T3. I mean, come on. We're,
what rock is this doctor living under? This is not even alternative procedures. This is
standards of care that doctors are ignoring and to the, you know, to the ill effect of their patients.
Yeah. And one reason why they might not be ordering those antibodies is because they think that
there's nothing that they can do or the patient can do, right? So a lot of the times they don't order
that because they still think that you can't reverse Hashimoto's, you know, disease in antibodies,
which is, I chuckle at that because I'm like, okay, so you're saying, like I, like my antibodies,
like, you know, it's just, you know, a miracle. No, it's not. And we see those trend down a lot, but
I will say on the other effect, I will have patients that their antibodies will not go down, but
a lot of it comes back to trauma, that autonomic nervous system in balance, you know, traumatic life
events, adrenals and stress. And I, you know, my patient population is a lot of mid 20s to late 40s
that women that are burning the candles at both ends, they're not working with their hormones. So,
you know, maybe when they're supposed to actually be relaxing, they're just staying up all night and
getting work done. And this can affect your, your body and actually precipitate autoimmune diseases.
And I don't, you know, it's not a coincidence that women are the ones that have the most autoimmune
diseases. Now, this can be for a lot of different hormonal reasons, but I just see burnout after burnout,
women in my office. And I feel it with them, you know, a lot of the times I draw on personal experiences
on, this is what you can do to help, you know, or I know it's tempting to stay up until midnight,
because you only get two hours to yourself a day, but you need to get sleep. Because if you're
not sleeping, your body can't repair overnight, you're not, you know, releasing proper hormones,
you know, between that golden hour, between 10 and 12, like growth hormone and your granulin and leptin,
that's when they're, you know, getting sorted out. So I think that women who are the main,
main group of autoimmune disease, you know, people that get it, they really have to just
pay attention to those lifestyle choices and sleep and diet are the big ones. And unfortunately,
they're running their kids to baseball games and practices. They're kind of being ignored. And then,
you know, a couple of years down the road after doing that for a long time, a couple of years,
an autoimmune disease comes out of it. And we really want to slow down that process, especially like
you said, with the spike protein running around, if it's not, when is it going to, not if, but when's
it going to happen, we really need to pay attention to how can we battle against this. And really,
like you said, this man made thing going on, we have to be more on the offense, make sure our body
is just a good environment for health. And that's, you know, the pillars of health, the sleep,
the nutrition, make sure you're exercising and moving your body, even if it's just a walk after
dinner. So it's really prevention of autoimmune disease because once you get that autoimmune disease,
once you get one, you're more likely to get another. So we're just trying to prevent those things from
happening. And it kind of goes back to the emergency room stories is that we want to prevent the
heart attack. We want to prevent the stroke, prevent dementia, all of that. And one thing I've noticed
that really frustrates me is a lot of these big organizations like the American Heart Association.
Like I remember I went to a local event and there was nothing about prevention. It was all about
treatment and what to do after your heart attack. And I'm like we're missing, we're missing what the
big thing that we need to do. And that's prevention. Well, and use, well, it's because they're all
funded by the big pharmaceutical companies. And they want you to have hard conditions because then
they're going to get you in a prescription life and sell you something every single month. And that's
unfortunate. You did mention that, you know, lots of times with autoimmune disease, you can't get
their antibodies down, but the key is getting them still in a state of remission so that there's not
as much destruction of that organ by looking at triggers. I think that's where a lot of practitioners
miss that point. They're like just trying to balance a person's like in Hashimoto's. There may be
using a more natural approach like armor or something like that, which yeah, maybe it is a little more
natural, but it's still not dealing with triggers still not dealing with cause like you're looking at
it. Does this person have more toxicity? Does this person have any mental issues? Does this person
have got issues? You have to, you know, take is, you know, you have to step far away enough from
that person's body to see the big picture and look at all those things and run the tests that you
need to run to discover those things and find those triggers that are stimulating further destruction.
So even if a person, because when you mentioned your antibodies got back down to normal rate,
I think there might be some people that might be discouraged like, oh, I've been trying so hard
now by anybody. It's still high. You can still be in a state of remission even with having elevated
antibodies. Sometimes they'll never go down. But you've got to find the triggers that are
stimulating destruction that will then cause symptoms and cause ill health. And that is sometimes
you need a practitioner to dig in deep and run some different labs and find out what those are.
Yeah, that's a great point. And a lot of the times patients get frustrated because they want to
get off their meds completely. And it depends on what level of destruction there was to those
thyroid cells. So sometimes yes, the goal would be to lower the thyroid meds to get you more
in balance. But sometimes like, or if you got surgery and had to get some removed, like you need to be
on some of your thyroid meds. But also, I think you bring up a good point just, you know, taking
armor is just not the way to go, you know, just because you go to a doctor and they're like, okay,
you know, I'm functional or integrative, like, because I use armor. And like you said, they need to dig
further, look for the triggers. Why is this happening? Not just I'm going to treat it the more natural
way. But why is your body mad at itself? What is triggering that? And it could be so many things. And
we also have to look at the thyroid is very sensitive. Our undercan organs are very sensitive to
chemicals and heavy metals. And our world is just full of chemicals, whether it's, you know, your
moldy coffee at Starbucks, lots of chemicals, or, you know, the packaged food you eat or just the
air you breathe. I mean, I know air quality in Ohio is really bad for, you know, like a week. And I
was just given everyone in my family knack. And we were just trying to be smart about it. So you
have to look at your environment, whether it comes from your, what you're washing your clothes in or
the makeup you're putting on your body. So we have to also look at those things because environmental
triggers can still be a trigger for thyroid health and damaging it. So it can get kind of complicated.
So yes, that's why you do want someone a practitioner to work with you. And that's, that's a nice
thing is that, you know, Kevin, we're just detectives, right? We've been doing this a long time. We,
like my intake form, I love it because it just really brings things out, whether it's a childhood
living environment or emotional trauma or, you know, chemical exposure when they were young. So all of
these things just put together the big health history because remember, it takes, you know, seven to
10 years for autoimmune diseases to kind of surface. But I would say COVID is really accelerated
that timeline, which is kind of interesting. But we need to look, you know, in the past, like
what triggered what happened? Was it a tick bite on vacation? Was it getting mono as a kid? And you've
been dealing with this, you know, for longer than you thought. So, but it's, it can get really
complicated. So that's why it's nice to have someone working in your corner that knows what to do,
how to treat these things. It's kind of like untagally the ball of best up yard sometimes, isn't it?
Yes, definitely. How do our listeners get a hold of you? Do you work with people across the United
States? Tell us a little bit of how your practice runs.
Yes. So I have my brick and mortar in Northwest Ohio. And you can come and see me there.
In person, I'm going to be launching in the end of August, middle of August, a small group program,
which will be great with weekly calls and also some health coaching. I do a lot of teaching information
for free on my Instagram and YouTube channel, which is the handle integrative doctor mom,
so integrative DR doctor mom. And I also have a podcast, the integrative health podcast with Dr.
Jen, which was on a little like sabbatical last year because things just got crazy with my kids.
And then I just I felt like I was ready to start doing it again. So I'm not good. I don't do every
week, but I try to do it the best I can, which is kind of what I encourage all my patients to do.
Do the best you can. You know, if you need to either be at your kids baseball game or record a podcast,
you know, go to your kids baseball game. So I think that that is kind of just what I do when I can.
And when I give when I can, but I try to do as much as I can on my social media,
giving real life tips and tricks because I know as a mother and then seeing my patients,
it's the real life that's hard to deal with, right? Because I'm in the in the weeds with everyone,
I guess is what I like to say. And I've been through it. I know what it feels like to be exhausted
as a thyroid patient and go to your doctor frustrated in tears. I was there. So I really, I know how
everyone feels if they're in that position and you can heal your body wants to heal and feel good.
So that's the really positive note about it. Well, thank you, Dr. Jen. You've been a wealth
of information. It's neat to see that you're, you know, your first role in life is to be a dedicated
mother. Thank you so much. Yes. Thank you. All right. We'll be back next time. Bye.